tom homan former acting ice director and
a fox news contributor is with me now
tom first of all when you see that video
of the little one holding his teddy bear
screaming
at those smugglers who left him behind i
know you will tell us that you
are not surprised by that but it is
heart shaking
it is heart shaking that's why i fight
so hard harrison that's why i've gotten
arguments with congress
that's why i get emotional on this
network sometimes because in 30 almost
35 years i've
i've dealt with many sad things i've
dealt with dying children
the good thing is the bourbon trolling
shop they're rescuing these children i
was down i've been down there four times
this year
i've seen board stations jump in the
river to say dying children
i seem to jump in the river and were
unable to save a child and the child
drowned
the men and women of the border patrol
are their only piece of humanity on that
border
the bite administration policies they
say humane tell me that's humane watch
that video
the the migra the children being dropped
over the wall the children been
abandoned on the ranches
it's the most inhumane policy i've seen
in my 35 years
so thank god for the men and women of
green who are standing on that front
line and saving lives they saved over 4
000 lives last year amen uh
you know i i do want to ask this because
i i know that you have said that a
national security risk
is is the next step in all of this and
that it would be great
are we there yet yeah we're there
and that's why i think governor abbott's
declaring national emergency his
troopers have
seized a record num a record uh amount
of fentanyl
and fentanyl spreads over this country
he killed over 64 000
americans during the last uh crisis on
the border and the
the the man who spoke just before i was
i didn't get his name he's exactly right
the criminal cartels controlled the
mexican u.s border
and joe biden administration handed it
to them they use this
humanitarian crisis they'll push
hundreds of family groups in one area
tie all the borbacho agents up so they
move their fentanyl their gang members
to unprotected areas which creates a
national security crisis
not accountant how many people on the
fbi uh
watch this have have gotten in
successfully that we didn't arrest
it's a severe national security crisis
you know what i just caught from what
you said and we're so focused on that
little one who's suffering who's been
abandoned by smugglers
i would imagine everybody was focused on
that child and that creates
a perforated area one one that you can
easily cross through for cartels and
smugglers
i totally get what you're saying tom
holman that that becomes then
a necessary distraction because you've
got to go to that child
boy it sounds like they know what
they're doing in terms of poking holes
at us i want to get to this the new york
times has obtained
documents now revealing president
biden's plans to overhaul the
immigration system
apparently he's about to push to allow
more people into the united states
aiming to
undo much of president trump's legacy
former white house senior adviser
stephen miller with this searing
response to the move
bottom line you have wealthy and
privileged white house staff
working to demolish the protections
ordinary working people
rely upon without an ounce of empathy or
concern
for their well-being tom your reaction
well i agree with steve but i i think
another thing i think
they're throwing gas on a lit flame
already you know show me
one thing one thing this administration
has done secretary the president
to slow the flow they're not they're
getting really good at releasing people
quickly and they're bragging about it
there's no overcrowding facilities we're
moving them quickly when you when you
brag about releasing people quickly
when you brag about even opening up more
policy bring more people in
what's it going to do you're throwing
gas on the fire that's just going to
bring more people it's more enticements
it equals a free health care equals no
detention equals quick release
it equals doc and amnesty and now
instead of talking about a consequence
of deterrence
instead of doing one thing just one
thing to slow the flow
so we don't see what we saw with this
little child we don't see dying children
and women being raped and cartel's
making billions they throw another
enticement out
i just can't believe it they doubled
down on the worst of the worst
do their job they've abandoned their
oaths they abandoned the men and women
of the border patrol they banned the
sovereignty in this nation
you can hate or love president trump i
don't care what people think
you can't deny that he gave us the most
secure border in my career
and by doing so when it leave
immigration down 80 how many women
didn't get raped how many children
didn't die how many children didn't get
abandoned how many americans didn't die
of overdose overdose
how many millions of the money how many
millions of dollars did the cartel not
make
president trump did it right agree or
disagree president
president bind has undone all of that
which puts this country at great risk
people are dying on that border so tom
you know you rest that on the shoulders
of the president
i would imagine in part because when he
handed this job off to the vice
president you would think okay well
maybe that person would actually do
something no it goes right back to the
president
and look at what we're learning about
vice president harris's team
reportedly panicked when president biden
gave her the border assignment
and her team has reportedly tried to
distance her
from the southern border crisis quote
unquote because
she wants political victories cnn
reporting the story
and offering this take republicans kind
of seized on that confusion and
they made it seem as though vice
president harris was going to be the new
border czar
parole uh was always going to be
focusing on these northern triangle
countries and the root causes of this
and they
saw her being linked to the border as a
potentially politically
perilous you know assignment task
she has wanted to emphasize both
internally and publicly frankly her team
has come out and said publicly look
we do not own the issues at the border
we are not managing the issues at the
border
it sounds like the vice president's team
chose
politics over all people those south of
the border who have suffered the way
that you described tom
and those of us who expect her to do her
job
because it's america and we're citizens
well look i don't care what cnn says
she's the vice president of the united
states
her responsibilities protect this nation
regardless she's named borders are
whatever
her responsibilities to this country and
our security and our safety
and securing that border is is a part of
that job and so
i she's a vice president bottom line
she's responsible she's going to wear
this tragedy
her and the president the secretary
they're going to wear this tragedy and
they should
because they have put this in motion
this is an open borders agenda
this isn't mismanagement this is this
isn't incompetence
this is by design this is what open
borders looks like and that's why we've
been fighting this
for so many years and they gave it all
up to win an election from the
progressive left
well and you've been forecasting the
stages of this so now we've entered the
national security risk zone and you say
it's
it's a dire situation already which is
why we saw texas governor abbott
uh you know declare a disaster down in
his state
so the next steps in all of this uh are
coming
and tom home and we will have you back
to unfortunately
navigate this it's always great to have
your expertise and your time
thanks for having me hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now